bioinformatics is the intersection of
informatics or the science of processing
data for storage and retrieval
and biology the study of living
organisms
this field developed tremendously in the
last several decades transforming life
sciences
enabling biotechnology and empowering
biomedical research
as a result came many new discoveries
that include new treatments
diagnostic assays and design strategies
for experimentation
importantly today there is a growing
appreciation among biologists and
clinicians for data
this includes new types of data
generation computational methods for
data
organization and analysis as well as
visualization approaches that show
statistical patterns in the context of
biological phenomena
in this video i will introduce you to
these important terms and topics which
we will discuss throughout the full
course
as a result of completing this course
you will see the broad applications of
next generation sequencing
by statistical methods of analysis as
well as computational tools that are
used to process
and mine big data moreover you will have
a clear understanding of the logic
behind bioinformatics analysis
in the context of cutting-edge research
projects and see how data science
methods can be used to study biological
phenomena
in conclusion you will also be able to
plan
how to take what you have learned and
apply it to an independent research
project
using tools and methods that we cover so
what is bioinformatics it is a
convergence of biology and data
where both are equally important as we
will see in the next few slides
who uses bioinformatics and who is it
for the answer
might have previously been statisticians
computer scientists or engineers
but the truth is that today more and
more biologists and clinicians are
expected to understand
as well as handle their own data to
publish and succeed
in both basic and translational research
projects
in fact biology itself is rapidly
acquiring the character of a data
science
this science is based on high throughput
technologies
that generate billions of data points
from genes proteins and other molecules
which characterize biological systems
and biological phenomena these data are
compiled
into large repositories that can be
systematically studied
to understand interrogate and establish
trends for many different applications
is such data available yes one such
repository
is maintained by the national center for
biotechnology information
which has a collection of peer-reviewed
articles biological data sets
and projects on various topics as you
can see
in the past several decades this
resource has been growing exponentially
today there are over 80 000 publicly
available data sets
in just one part of ncbi called geo
or gene expression omnibus
such data repositories contain data sets
on
thousands of genes in each sample with
tens
or even hundreds of samples per data set
so what can be done with this data
anyone
including you can find a relevant data
set learn how to analyze it
and discover something new about the
world that we live in
that's why this course in bioinformatics
is a good place to start
it will provide you with a full roadmap
to go from a to z
or from basics to advanced and
cutting-edge bioinformatics methods
in the context of projects that you can
learn from
we call this roadmap omixlogic it
consists of online coursework
interactive tutorials as well as
projects and datasets from peer-reviewed
research articles to get started
you will need a solid overview of key
technologies that are used to generate
data
omix technologies these courses will
include
practical exercises to see how this data
can be analyzed
and guidance on developing a project of
your own
using various analytical tools and
publicly available biological data sets
in the next few lessons we will review
important terminology
provide perspectives from experts in
this exciting field
and review how quizzes allow you to see
what you have learned including
assignments for hands-on practice
in these assignments you will see how
the practical
analysis skills help find answers
to biological questions we'll start our
review
from an introduction to genomic data so
we will focus on next generation
sequencing to
find variation in genomics
then we will talk about transcriptomic
data
or rna-seq sequencing that allows us to
measure
different products of genes including
gene isoforms
and their levels of abundance and
alternative splicing
then we'll talk about epigenomic
regulation
and how we can study epigenetic
variation
or non-coding variants that lead to
different levels of expression patterns
focusing primarily on chromatin
immunoprecipitation
and whole genome by sulfate sequencing
data
we'll also talk about the microbiome and
the ability to study microorganisms
using metagenomic sequencing
including 16s ribosomal rna and
functional metagenomics
then we'll talk about biostatistics
coding
and machine learning in the context of
these important skills
you'll see how important it is to
understand what these methods do
how to visualize data and how to develop
good reproducible research techniques in
different coding libraries
and repositories the way these courses
are organized is that they provide you
with insights
into terminology and the biological
context
then provide you with a map of different
topics
an introduction to a data set or a
project
analysis techniques in the context of
interactive pipeline builders
and help monitor the progress with a
point system for every activity that you
do
the interactive analysis pipelines will
help establish
what's called a bioinformatics analysis
pipeline
logic so there you will see color-coded
maps
an explanation of methods using
informative pop-ups
a variety of input and output formats
for data analysis visualization and
interpretation
and help you develop a sense of a guided
process which will
lead to reproducible workflow analysis
that you can share
these types of pipelines will cover
major areas for sequence alignment
rna sequencing analysis evolutionary
studies
machine learning methods variant calling
and structure analysis
many of such methods are going to be
provided with the source code
where you will see how the methods can
be
implemented in different languages like
r and python
and how those could be changed by their
settings
and specific libraries for visualization
then we will see how experts use such
methodology
to answer biological research questions
so here we will introduce you to a
number of curated data sets
that you can use for practice and we
will use a review methodology where we
will take at both the
abstract the method section the results
and the discussion to think about what
the authors did
to produce the results that they have
found
as a result you will be able to look at
independent projects from
data sets that you have been studying
methods that you've learned
and combine them into novel projects
many of the students that have completed
these courses
have now gone on to present their own
research studies
using publicly available data sets and
the methods that we discuss in this
course
importantly you will see how
bioinformatics
allows you to leverage big data in a
variety of different contexts
to understand the relationship between
clinical and omix data
identify new strategies for therapeutic
intervention
and a novel diagnostic approach that
helps us understand disease
at the molecular level for the duration
of this course you will be using the t
bioinfo platform
for large data analysis and integration
of multi-omics data
and to learn all of the coding
techniques you will be introduced to the
omics logic code playground which allows
you to
practice and see the correct way to
write code in r
and python this course will
introduce you to bioinformatics where
you will see
processing bioinformatics data
visualization techniques
statistical analysis data mining and
biological interpretation
all with the goal to help you develop an
overview
of bioinformatics its applications and
how you personally can use these methods
for data analysis